RR has to win
pride of every Indian
[Music]
and must put me on the top of the world
not to not to winner mm kiravani feeling
on top of the world the composer of the
RR track took home the trophy for best
original song at the 2023 Oscars thank
you Academy
[Applause]
I grew up listening to The Carpenters
and now here I am with the Oscars
he made it a moment to pay tribute to
the Carpenters putting his own spin on
one of their classics
there was only one wish on my mind
so was rajamaulis and my families
[Applause]
to win
pride of every Indian
[Music]
and must put me on the top of the world
and then made history with the win
marking the first time in Indian films
one in the category it feels like top of
the world
standing on the top of the world and I'm
very feeling very proud for my country
and my the whole team who just dedicated
their energy and time for this song
including Mr Chandra Bose
just ahead of the honor viewers got to
see a high energy
deep viral dance
and all
every time we were shooting every time
there was a take he was like no you know
what your legs need to be a little more
in sync I was like you know what that
doesn't happen we have different styles
you know we are different you know each
person has a different style of dancing
so but for him it was so important that
in the film when two friends are alike
when they align together you really
don't need to look at each other you
know that you're one
[Music]
do not